en este vídeo voy a hacer una aclaración
respecto al vídeo pasado que hemos hecho
en el vídeo pasado comparábamos 4
séptimos con 3 séptimos y de hecho vimos
que si nosotros dibujamos estos cuatro
séptimos se vería de este tamaño
mientras que 3 séptimos se vería de este
otro y entonces visiblemente podemos
saber que 4 séptimos es más grande que 3
séptimos aquí se ve más grande este
dibujo que pasa cuando tengo un entero
de este tamaño y dibujo tres séptimos
tendría uno
3 séptimos y de esta manera ustedes me
pudieran decir oye se ve más grande que
los 4 séptimos que tenemos anteriormente
sin embargo y aquí es donde quiero hacer
la aclaración es importante que ustedes
me dan únicamente la comparación entre
enteros iguales es decir no podemos
comparar 4 séptimos de un ratoncito con
4 séptimos de un elefante de este tamaño
ok si estamos comparando es importante
que tomemos en cuenta que el entero debe
de ser siempre el mismo y aquí le voy a
poner una nota donde está que el entero
vamos a ponerle mismo
entero
ok tenemos el mismo entero que es en
este caso este cuadro amarillo y
entonces podemos hacer la comparativa
entre ellos dos sin embargo aquí tengo
otro tipo de entero que esté entero es
azul y naturalmente serían diferentes
las medidas cuando nosotros hablamos de
fracciones como un número es decir ya no
estamos comparando ratones ni elefantes
cuando simplemente los comparamos como
un número
entonces lo que haremos decirnos
directamente a una recta numérica
recuerda que un entero en la recta
numérica voy a hacer la más bonita
recuerda que un entero en una recta
numérica significa el espacio que se
encuentra entre el 0 y el 1
un entero cuando hablamos de estas
fracciones únicamente como número pues
entonces sabemos que esto está dividido
en 7 por el denominador tendremos 1 2 3
4 5
siete partes iguales estamos de acuerdo
donde tendríamos aquí cada uno de estos
avances como un séptimo
un séptimo dos séptimos
3 séptimos
4 séptimos
5 séptimos
7 séptimos o un entero ok si nosotros
hacemos esta comparación de fracciones
como número tendremos entonces que 3
séptimos nos representa un salto tres
veces a la derecha del cero contemos 123
donde entonces tendremos 3 séptimos aquí
y si buscamos los 4 séptimos los
tendremos con un salto todavía más a la
derecha 1 2 344 séptimos y aquí podemos
comparar como números en un entero estas
fracciones únicamente hago hincapié
acuérdate que cuando hagas una
comparación de fracciones debe de ser el
mismo entero no podemos comparar ratones
con elefantes porque sería distinto
cuando estés comparando números vete
directo a la recta numérica y con ello
notarás cuál es la diferencia entre
ambos nos vemos en otro vídeo